you
hi everyone is cherry Aban leaches org
and going to play a 5-2 game
okay let's try c4 all right I guess
we're gonna have a Benko huh
yeah let's decline it actually what this
wasn't my preferred way to decline it
should have considered that a tie like
that a four line but uh this is another
approach as well just make sure that a
file doesn't open up I could do a for
right now let's shoot for a for right
now and then 85 maybe I'm gonna hold off
on that let's get some more development
in maybe I could gain a valuable temple
against the Queen instead of doing it
with the pawn um light square bishop
where do you belong I'm gonna go just
one step stay out of 95 stuff let's go
here I like that I don't have to worry
about this Bishop move so if I play
Knight here in 95 I could consider maybe
f4 but then there's an IG 4 okay I'm
thinking about 92 right now and why not
what's wrong with that I'm another
Knight 95 I play here in the knight is
trapped yeah I think they just have to
go back and they they do so that was
some it's a waste of time there I don't
want to allow Knight to be 6 I think
this is where I do want to play a 5 no
85 yeah I know I'm trying to control
this night of course you know a night to
be six I could have considered Knight a5
into c6 that's another one to try and
why I really want to go for this type of
break maybe this might be a pretty good
way forward F for Bishop f3 rook e1 pawn
push are they lining up you 6 maybe I
just play within the structure and by
that I mean something like this Queen d2
Bishop h6 keep pressure on d6 which you
know makes this less appealing for sure
I'd have three pieces on it at the end
of it
maybe e5 at some point but basically I
don't want to play this position where I
move my F pawn I want to keep this guy
home as a good shelter for my King if I
do move my F pawn I always have to worry
a Bishop d4 with check alright so I
could already consider maybe e5 but
let's build up some there's no rush with
this pawn break nice improving move
would be h3 it's a nice little flight
square in there how could I improve my
rook he's doing a fine job on a1
supporting this pawn who is quite
cramping to the black side okay so this
is where I could go in for a dark square
Bishop exchange and maybe then look to
attack their King after all with f4 and
e5 meanwhile black is up to this
maneuver
let's go for this are they going to
invite my queen into their physician
I think 97 is best wow that's really
weakening so they gave up their dark
square bishop and just weakened with
their last move f6 and basically their
seventh rank because when I take they
have to take with their F pawn so their
King is that much more exposed so I'm
considering now rook a to d1 I don't
think I need my a or up to defend my a
pawn anymore rook a to d1 or do I
capture and then play rook a to d1 and
put a media pressure on d6 there bit
backward in development knights on the
edge I think I want to make sure this
position is opened if I take on e6 I'm
helping the rook out it has some play on
the F file but I don't think that that
should be so much of a concern
um yeah let's take look a 2d one next
threatening the pond I'm expecting Queen
c7 this is a strong Knight Bishop to g4
how can I improve my Bishop Bishop g4
seems like a good spot
although Knight to f6 hmm their knight
on b8 can't move otherwise they drop
that pawn rook F to e 1 f2 is sensitive
hmm Bishop g4 Knight d2 f6 oh let's go
here I have to be a bit set a bit
careful now of my f2 pawn it's
unprotected in my eyes one attacker one
defender so Queen f6 Queen f7 I have to
react here most likely Knight f6 strikes
at this pawn okay
i D was Bishop here mm-hmm
maybe my queen isn't so well placed on
h6 actually let's go here I'm opposite
their Queen and this actually stops d5
for the moment and threatens 'if I've to
break up their Center my bishop secures
my Queens position by watching over g4
I'd still like to get in this move but I
think well I'm pretty sure you do this
move here right now they're missing
anything
I don't think so this is a good this is
a good moment to break up their pawn
center Queen here threatens mate on g2
it would not be the first time I've
fallen for something like that
although you know queen c6 right now I
just have a counterpunch with Bishop f3
but if the e pawn is exchanged for their
deep on he's the heart of this three-man
group here so these guys will
immediately become weakened two isolated
pawns so this is a desirable exchange my
e pawn for their deep on know how to
recapture if I take what the knight I'm
dropping the a pawn but maybe who cares
about that if there's something exciting
happening over here against their king
that is really weakened he takes pawn
let's just keep the balance material
wise and play against their structure
yeah it suits this should still be fine
I've got a minute advantage are they
really considering avoiding the Queen
exchange no okay how could I improve
further this is a weak point um how
about I play Bishop here I open my rook
size and my Bishop is known a better
position also I have this move hitting
the rook and the pawn and a knight on
this square will be a monster hitting
the bishop hitting a6 did not consider
that move that c5 pawn isn't going
anywhere is he let's just back up c5
on isn't going anywhere I want to take
here and beyond the bishop let's take
this should be collapsing now on the
bishop Amani six if this pond is hit
it's worth check he's taken it's worth
check if he ever moves I have access to
their seventh ranked Bishop c8 under
developing take a bunch of times on d5
and net another pawn okay what's wrong
with grabbing on e6 could take with the
rook even let's just keep it simple grab
another pawn insert a check now let's
just recap sure I'm on the bishop trying
to scare away my rook let's just stay
coordinated hmm let's give him a kick I
might do some time gainers yeah let's
get a time gainer in there that's I'm
gainer
not a time burner a time gainer and
they're right okay let's go here and
they might work themselves into a self
pin they did I could take and defend my
Bishop Bishop here's a threat did not
see that move unfortunately okay I have
to rihwan this one now
let's go here are they going to play
hook to a1 I could get them in a pin
again okay one rookie one else on a6
rook c5 Bishop takes pawn we'll have it
three versus two on the Kings side at
the end I guess that's what we're gonna
go with and I'm gonna try to win this
which will be difficult because hey I'm
down on time and I don't even have the
correct cleaning pawn let's see maybe
this is one of my better chances to lose
I have to stop Bishop to b5 now I've
worked myself into a pin unfortunately
not cool at all
now after defend against all these uh
attacking was against my bishop
maybe I play here let's try this with
rip - f2 there are better ways to go
about this run that's for sure King here
Bishop g2 rook ending alone alright
let's go here Bishop to g2 don't want to
fall for Brooke h1 mate let's see if I
could work some magic with this they're
keeping that Bishop on interesting okay
how to improve here Bishop f3 King g2
king f2 evening out on time my king is
on the light square for just a moment
there we go
I got g4 let's get over here
operate on the dark square your
positioning another pawn on a light
square I want the rooks off hmm they're
offering a draw now I'm gonna try
something still I'm not sure what maybe
I could try for some tricks Bishop d3
okay they have that I have to defend
mm-hmm that's a good way to do it I
guess in the end I don't really have
anything and that was just repetition
wasn't it yeah it was just repetition
there it is okay
mm missed opportunity there for sure and
that ending we go into the analysis
mm-hmm okay
I liked how he played the opening
certainly could have converted that in
game much better being up to ponds and
yeah you know what I missed that rook to
what move was that when I went over to
pin their Bishop I missed this resource
right here rook to d1 and that really
turned the tables being up upon this is
really tough to win on the Kings side
three versus
- mmm okay let's have a look at it
without the evaluation for a moment
although I don't think it would be too
bad to even put it on right now it'll
probably be saying that I'm the better
side just the space advantage and I'm
pretty sure it will hold as that for a
great portion of this game this other
line that I was referring to early on
with like a declined Banco gambit of
sorts is a for a nun takes the night
here efore and Bishop takes I've played
this and I think a couple standard games
just uh another approach this a four in
reply to the Benko b5 but I went with
the captures and then basically decline
it with v6 keep the a file closed d6
just getting our pieces out Queen takes
yeah so they lost some time around here
this Knight g4 move I'm pretty sure that
this is a good reaction because he's hit
twice and where does he go but back to
f6 if he goes here f4 wins the knight
and this isn't really helping because I
still have f4 and now although hang on I
have to be careful Knight - III if they
played Knight to e5 here what would I do
on 95 well at the very least I could
give him a boot and then give him a boot
so I'm advancing and pushing my opponent
back gaining some valuable moves
valuable Tempe
so this really can't be correct for
black I'm not I really don't know what
the computer would be suggesting for
black right about here mm-hmm
tough to say this bishop struggles for
one you know they're working with well I
have the space advantage black still has
all minor pieces so they're still
struggling in other words to find out
adequate squares for their minor pieces
if they play a five trying for this
light square bishop exchange I have the
b5 square now to operate on it may seem
far-fetched but you know I could try to
make these kind of maneuvers with my
knight and focus in on that weak point
b5 now if they go if they do go for
something like this getting a minor
piece exchanged I'm not sure if Queen
here but just to illustrate the idea I
could really focus on the be 5 square I
don't even know you I don't even know
that I would need to go with this Knight
maybe just jumping in right here Bishop
d2 to c3 to offset the dark square
bishop and then maybe look for this this
is strong piece okay the short story in
other words is if you're trying to get
rid of the light square bishop with a 5
it comes with the cost the weakness
would that be 5 square so you know let
me turn it on right around here close to
upon advantage yeah just kind of
skimming through or nothing just doing a
quick blunder check I guess IG for the
queen bee for its computer esque no fear
no fear of a 5r okay for getting the
Queen may be kicked
well for the moment ephors hit so this
would be a more human-like reply but I
guess this is fine you know Knight takes
Knight takes Queen takes rook here and
the Queen is gonna be trapped yeah sure
I saw this yeah oh who did not see that
variation coming you know a five rook a
for you sack this pawn rook F for G for
ideas yeah okay anyhow computer computer
move but there's a fine reply you know
you don't have to see this you could
play something quite natural develop a
piece and defend so they went with
Knight G for this really didn't turn out
too well
I gained some time and yeah this is this
an important moment because you know
this is like how would you say this is
like middle game planning different
different avenues that you could take in
a game this might be quite tempting to
to go with f4 and e5 as mentioned I
wanted to play within the structure I
just wanted to improve still my pieces
further and I can do that I can look to
do exactly what I did in the game which
is forming a battery on this diagonal
and go for a dark square Bishop exchange
and then and then go from there
see see what moves black has thrown back
at me and maybe they weaken their King
position somewhat and I could start to
focus more on their weakened King
position as a result and in the meantime
I'm not weakening weakening my own King
position if I do get my F on involved if
I'm trying something like this there are
some weaknesses I'm creating III I'm
exposed
this diagonal this ranked vulnerable to
Bishop d4 checks just throwing some
stuff out there it's running through my
mind I this is a much safer or a
conservative approach and it's perfectly
fine Bishop f4 queenie 822 it's fine
with this idea giving me a pond
advantage i take happy with that i guess
i could do this but it didn't feel as
convincing to have this square clogged
up yeah I wanted I wanted to if I'm
gonna play rook a to d1 I want to be
biting at something here I want to see
one of my opponents pawns directly so
that's why I first took and yeah that's
what I would have expected evaluation
wise here close to two Queen d2 that's
pretty direct huh just add one more
piece on this and he simply falls Queen
d2 hit three times defended twice can't
be defended again yeah that works
what's the trick here oh I'm rook here I
have a knight move hmm takes Queen
Knight takes Queen with Czech pawn takes
Knight Queen takes rook that's what
black gets for having that night on e
phi r that night on e 8 of having that
disconnect between the rooks okay well I
could have played Queen d2 right away
but instead I played rook after d1 you
know this is where I spent some time you
know I I was certainly hesitant to do
this because I recognized the weakness
on f2 hmm yeah it's unfair
acted as soon as I do this Queen here
Queen here pressure against f2 so just
immediately Queen to d2 was only until a
move or two later that I finally saw
best to fold the Queen back okay does
like Queen III and e5 okay and they de
for two and a half I don't know I guess
there's multiple good mouse here Bishop
c4 can't be so bad huh Knight a for mmm
what did i do i played 97 and then this
but this other night could also hunt
down c5 okay i didn't really see that
yeah i mean i was only looking at this
move with tempo against the rook and
then getting at c5 which is which is
fine 94 i could have played here Lana
could have plus five that's ad plus four
plus two
what's better right around here not
taking this Knight but this one oh man
many opportunities even here just grab
another pond oh well oh man no it's back
to tough it's back to tough here upon
advantage not even yeah this isn't going
to be enough here yeah but writing it
right in these complications to Brooks
really well centralized and I could just
take right here instead of recapturing
this is the more advanced night you
should be looking to take him out and
spit him but I was to be honest I was
completely blind even taking
here's just in recapture mode takes
night-night takes their yeah and the
other thing is that I get to maintain my
structure although I don't know how
great of a structure this is to be
perfectly honest he is backward but I
should be looking more beyond structure
at this stage there should be I mean I'm
up to ponds here really active rooks
they have a more vulnerable King still a
lot of pieces on the board maybe put
their king position into question Knight
takes d5 that would have been really
clean son takes here I'm recapturing and
hitting everything and this game goes no
further
they're probably resigned right around
here ah man too many missed
opportunities in this one did any
blunders come about in this ending I
don't think so
yeah I don't think I had anything you
know they're just they keep the rook on
the board I can't force the exchange and
he stays active and nice nice hold there
at the end they're pretty clean and we
had that little repetition at the end
okay interesting game the Benko gambit
declined feel free to leave any feedback
in this in the comment section below to
this video and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you